[Music]
do you
long for an elegant weapon from
a more civilized age something less
clumsy and random
as you hone your sensitivity to the
force
you may wonder what if lightsabers were
real
how hot would the plasma burn
how does a lightsaber know when to stop
and would this weapon require a license
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if lightsabers were real
okay for the uninitiated all three of
you
a lightsaber is the fictional weapon of
choice for the jedi
the sith and other beings who are
sensitive to the force
in the star wars franchise back here on
earth though
lightsaber duels are a competitive sport
using led lit rigid polycarbonate
replicas of the movie props
these very non-lethal weapons may
emit the same glow we marveled at on the
big screen but
they're basically a one meter long glow
stick
but if lightsabers were real
how much power would they use
[Music]
whether you're looking to conquer a
universe or save one
the power contained within this metal
hilt would
certainly help you achieve your goals
according to the mythology of star wars
these weapons are powered by
equally mythical kyber crystals
but contrary to its name this weapon
isn't a laser sword so if you want to
arm yourself in this reality
you'd need to harness the power of
plasma
and by the way that's canon so don't at
me
plasma is an ionized gas and it's
considered to be the fourth
state of matter this electrical gas
cloud
is made up of atoms broken into
electrically charged particles
with both negatively charged electrons
and
positively charged ions but
if you were to press a button and
release this plasma bursts at will
how could you control it well
you'd need a strong magnetic field
otherwise the plasma you released would
extend
over 100 meters killing everyone
including you
the magnetic fields would counteract the
plasma's
increasing pressure keeping the plasma
confined
in a long narrow shape the international
thermonuclear
experimental reactor is a takamak that
contains the strongest magnetic walls on
earth
harnessing the energy of fusion it took
nine suppliers seven years to create the
magnets for
it it also happens to be 830 cubic
meters big
you are going to need something a lot
smaller
and stronger before you go into battle
and if the plasma isn't contained
properly
one clash between two lightsabers would
end the duel
by vaporizing you and your opponent
magnetic reconnection is a force that
involves
two plasmas colliding with different
magnetic fields
as the plasmas come near each other the
magnetic fields around them would
realign and release a deadly amount of
energy
in the terms of a different movie think
of it as
crossing the streams and if that isn't
bad enough
if the magnetic fields were even
slightly off
each swing could send plasma flying
everywhere
but why are the magnetic fields
different in each lightsaber
well because you want your own color
obviously
whether you're wielding a purple
lightsaber or a green one
the colors will depend on how hot the
plasma burns
as the atoms within the plasma lose
energy
they release a light and the photons
energy
is also related to the wavelength of the
light different wavelengths of light
look like different colors to us a
sinister looking lightsaber like
lord vader's would have a temperature
around
700 degrees but if you wanted to build a
lightsaber tribute to
obi-wan kenobi to get the blue color
you would need a temperature of around 6
000 degrees
each lightsaber would contain a unique
magnetic field
specific to the heat of its plasma this
handheld plasma cutter would rival the
strongest weapons grade technology
in existence in 2012
a united states company developed the
metal vapor torch
which produces a flame moving over 2500
meters per second
at temperatures of over 27 degrees
since it's more powerful than any
technology produced by the
military-industrial complex legally
acquiring a lightsaber
would probably be a bit more complicated
than applying for a gun license
well at least we hope it would be after
all
the power within this metal hilt would
be greater than a nuclear reactor
so if you want to take down general
grievous
your lightsaber would need at least 20
megawatts of power
and with that much energy you could
power over
40 000 households in the uk
but if you'd rather power this
lightsaber without an
ac cord hooked up to a bulky power
source
you'd need trillions of nano batteries
still being developed in testing phases
researchers predict that the future of
our
increasingly miniaturized technology
lies in these powerful macroscopic
batteries
think of all that raw power compressed
in such a small area
it's a lot like neural mints from neuro
the sponsor of this episode
their patented cold pressed gum and
mints are
supplements used by academics olympians
and
those of us stuck at home looking to
better our minds and do more
and since you need jedi-like patients at
this moment
well try the new calm and clarity which
uses ingredients
scientifically shown to reduce stress
and stabilize your mood
instead of taking a huge dose of
supplements in the morning
take neural gum throughout the day no
matter where you are these portable gum
and mints
are gluten-free sugar-free vegan and
they work faster than any drink go to
get neuro.com to order and
better your state of mind now that's
g-e-t-n-e-u-r-o
dot com use the promo code what if for
15
off your first order and carry the power
to improve your mind
right in your pocket because your body
like this lightsaber
needs a power source that's easy to
carry
owning a working lightsaber would
definitely be a childhood fantasy come
to life
but ironically as the technology behind
plasma containment and power cells
progress
were more likely to move away from this
reality
just as drone strikes have replaced the
cavalry
creating a confined beam of plasma
probably
wouldn't bring us an age of futuristic
swashbuckling
instead we'd probably use that
destructive technology on a more massive
scale
uh speaking of which that's no moon
oh geez what if
we could build the death star
well that's a story for another
what if